SIERRA: You know you’ve made it to the highest
level of prestige when you get to meet the
Pope.
Actors, artists, athletes and politicians
- they all clamor for a handshake with his
holiness.
But aside from his starpower, the Pope also
has a lot of actual power.
He runs a massive organization that serves
over 1.3 billion Catholics worldwide, nearly
a fifth of the global population.
On any given issue, you may find the church’s
position agreeable or egregious.
What you may not realize though is that for
some 2,000 years the Pope has been at the
center of global affairs.
He has a seat at the table alongside heads
of state, and is sought after for his distinct
form of influence and diplomacy.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why it
Matters.
Today, The Pope’s one-of-a-kind role in
international relations.
Reagan Library: If men and women hope to transform
society, they must begin by changing their
own hearts first.
American Rhetoric Online Speech Bank: As a
nation faces increasingly complex political
and ethical issues of our time, I am confident
that the American people will find their religious
beliefs as a precious source of insight, to
live a more human and free society.
CBS New York: Peace is not simply the absence
of war, but the work of justice.
SIERRA: Let's dive right into it.
When you look at lists of the most powerful
people in the world that come out every year,
you often find the Pope in, you know, top
10.
And he's next to people like Joe Biden or
Vladimir Putin or, you know, probably a Kardashian.
And, it occurs to me that I don't really understand
why the Pope is powerful.
So is the Pope powerful, and what kind of
power does he wield?
BYRNES: The question of whether he's powerful
is a difficult question.
I think he is.
I think there are three reasons.
First is, as we know, he leads this huge global
institution of the Catholic Church.
There's over a billion Catholics.
He has ready access to them through encyclicals,
through sermons that priests and bishops give.
So because of that and because I think he's
sort of prominently dressed and presented
as a religious figure in a world that takes
that seriously, he's surrounded by a media
circus of incredible intensity and attention.
SIERRA: This is Timothy Byrnes.
He is a professor of political science at
Colgate University, he’s also the author
of four books about the Catholic church’s
role in politics and global affairs.
BYRNES: And, since the middle of the 20th
century, popes have used modern forms of communication
and travel to take advantage of this.
So he's on Twitter, for example, Pontifex,
millions of followers.
He travels all over the world.
So he's this major sort of religious figure
leading the largest single religious institution
in the world.
That's one reason.
But he's also the leader of the Catholic hierarchy
throughout the world.
And by that, I mean every bishop in the world
is appointed by the Pope personally, and he
is the leader of each national hierarchy or
conference.
So when you think about world politics or
international relations, whatever country
is interacting with another country.
There are Catholics in those countries, and
they are led by bishops who are appointed
by and led by the Pope.
He's involved with all of these national hierarchies
all over the world.
And then finally, and really kind of oddly,
to be honest with you, he's a formal participant
in diplomatic relations.
The Pope, the Holy See, at the moment has
diplomatic relations with 183 countries, including
the United States, for example.
So he has access to international relations
in a way that no other religious leader could
even imagine having.
He's a permanent observer at the United Nations.
He's invited as a formal participant in UN
conferences and conventions.
SIERRA: Did you get that, relations with 183
countries, for perspective that’s more than
the U.S. and US does a lot of diplomacy.
And this gets at the crux of it, the Pope’s
role on the world stage is not just symbolic,
or religious.
He’s involved in negotiations and diplomacy
on a daily basis.
SIERRA: Can you tell me a little bit about
the structure of the Vatican's foreign policy
arm?
Do they have a state department?
BYRNES: They do.
There's a person who's called the Vatican
secretary of state, interestingly enough.
There's two people below him.
One runs the kind of internal church matters
and the other, the undersecretary for relations
with states, he runs, they're all he, of course,
runs relations with states.
So yes, it's a kind of a state department,
and they have country desks.
They have regional leaders, just like any
state department would in a country.
And then they have these ambassadors, they're
called nuncios or apostolic delegates, but
mostly nuncios.
Those are sent to these countries with which
the Vatican has diplomatic relations.
And then interestingly enough, the countries
with whom the Holy See has diplomatic relations,
there are ambassadors from those countries
in Rome.
So like the United States has an ambassador
who lives in Rome and who interacts with the
Holy See and the Pope pretty much as any other
diplomat would.
So he has this really unique place in the
world.
He leads this huge religious institution,
which brings with it enormous amounts of,
I'm interested you mentioned, Kardashians,
a sort of celebrity focus of this global religious
figure.
He heads the hierarchies in all countries
around the world as they interact with politics
and international relations.
And then he's a diplomatic legal player in
international relations and UN processes.
SIERRA: Is the Pope the only religious leader
welcomed into these discussions?
BYRNES: Formally, yes, I mean you don't have
diplomatic relations with Islam or Orthodoxy
or Judaism or any other religion.
So in formal terms, for sure, he is.
But there are other religious leaders, we
can think about Islamic leaders in Iran, for
example, who are certainly players in international
relations largely through their leadership
of an individual state, and so those religious
leaders do have a certain political role to
play.
But in terms of transnational global religious
leaders, no, I'm waiting for someone to come
along who can mention anyone who's even in
the same category.
SIERRA: Before we go any further, there are
three phrases we’re using in this episode
- the pope, the Holy See, and the Vatican.
They refer to different things, but they often
get used interchangeably.
You can think about it sort of like the President,
the Executive Branch, and the White House.
One is a person, one is an organization, and
one is a place.
The pope is the person in charge, the Holy
See is the organization he’s in charge of,
and the Vatican, or Vatican City - is the
place where that organization is located.
BYRNES: The Vatican is the headquarters of
the international Catholic Church in Rome.
So it comprises St. Peter's.
It comprises a bunch of other buildings that
are used administratively, residentially.
Vatican City is about a 100-acre micro-state,
which was ceded to the church and the Holy
See in the 1920s as part of the Lateran Accord.
So Vatican City if anyone's ever been there
as a tourist, that's when you walk into St.
Peter's Square and you're no longer in Italy.
The Vatican are those buildings that house
the international headquarters of the Catholic
Church.
SIERRA: So it's its own country to itself?
BYRNES: It is.
SIERRA: Because I went as a kid, I don't remember
doing a passport thing.
BYRNES: No, there are no passports, but I'm
surprised you didn't do what my kids did,
which is they put one foot in Italy and one
foot in Vatican City and go back and forth.
SIERRA: I mean that's pretty cool.
And the pope lives there?
BYRNES: Yeah.
The Pope is the bishop of Rome, actually.
He's elected by the College of Cardinals to
serve as the bishop of Rome and, as bishop
of Rome, he also serves as what's called the
Supreme Pontiff of the Catholic Church.
So he is, in a sense, the head bishop of all
Catholics throughout the world.
SIERRA: And the president or king of the Vatican,
in that sense, then?
BYRNES: Well, again, I would say Vatican City,
he is the absolute ruler.
They don't use the word, king, or certainly
not president.
But he is, in fact, legally the absolute ruler
of the micro-state of Vatican City.
SIERRA: So the pope has a unique combination
of institutional, diplomatic, and soft power.
But what does this look like in reality?
Well, a lot of it is happening every day behind
the scenes.
But every once in a while, these interactions
make history.
BYRNES: When Julian Assange released WikiLeaks,
one of the things that was released that drew
my attention, but maybe not yours, was that
there were a huge number of documents within
the United States State Department which reflected
the communications between the US State Department
and the Holy See.
And they were fascinating.
This was under President George W. Bush and
Obama, mostly.
The US diplomatic leaders acknowledged and
recognized that the Holy See was a unique
actor in international relations because it
wasn't just a state.
So you read cables and documents from State
Department leaders in the Obama administration,
for example, saying like I would say, there's
nobody else like this.
These people are kind of diplomatic representatives
of a global institution, and we can work with
them on all kinds of issues having to do with
Middle Eastern politics, having to do with
climate change, having to do with diplomatic
relations with Cuba, which is a fascinating
story I'd like to tell.
Sierra: I’d love to hear that story.
BYRNES: So as I'm sure you know, the United
States broke off diplomatic relations with
Cuba after the Castro revolution.
The United States imposed an economic embargo
on Cuba for decades.
And, so the United States and Cuba not only
didn't have diplomatic relations, they almost
didn't talk to each other at all.
It was like a basic fact of American electoral
college dynamics that you just couldn't even
talk about relations with Cuba.
Obama was interested in reaching out to Cuba.
This was just something he thought would be
a historic step that he could take, but he
knew that he couldn't do it himself.
And so what he did was he contacted prominent
Catholic bishops in the US who, remember,
are not only American citizens, they're also
bishops of the Catholic Church who are in
communion with the bishop of Rome, the Pope,
and have these kinds of relationships with
other bishops around the world.
And, so Catholic bishops in the US and Catholic
bishops in Cuba began to communicate to each
other through diplomatic pouches sent from
the Holy See in the Vatican to the US State
Department in the United States.
So the Vatican or the Holy See served as a
kind of a kind of honest broker with full
secrecy and discretion between the Cuban government
and the United States government as mediated
by Cuban bishops and American bishops.
And then one day Barack Obama called a press
conference and said…
New York Times, President Obama: Good afternoon.
Today the United States of America is changing
its relationship with the people of Cuba,
in the most significant changes in our policy
in more than 50 years, we will end an outdated
approach that for decades has failed to advance
our interests, and instead we will begin to
normalize relations between our two countries.
BYRNES: And that was done through the church.
SIERRA: The Vatican had contacts on both sides
- in part because there were large catholic
communities on both sides.
And they used that trust to open a door that
had been closed for decades.
Now, we should mention that the Trump Administration
undid this diplomatic progress with Cuba a
few years later, but that’s another story.
The church is involved in negotiations all
the time.
And to understand that better we wanted to
speak to someone who has been in the room
during these discussions.
For that we turn to Francis Campbell, formerly
a British Ambassador to the Holy See, he is
now the president of the University of Notre
Dame in Australia.
He was interviewed by Why It Matters producer
Asher Ross, who’s making his debut on the
show.
SIERRA: Hey Asher!
ROSS: Hey Gabby!
SIERRA: Okay take it away.
ROSS: On the international stage, we're used
to the idea that countries are supposed to
act in their own interests, or the interest
of their citizens.
That's their essential goal.
What is the Vatican's goal?
What drives them?
CAMPBELL: One of the most obvious interests
it would pursue in different parts of the
world is religious freedom.
Very broadly, it's pursuing human rights.
It pursues aspects of disarmament, global
disarmament.
It pursues aspects very much around the eradication
of poverty.
Very much around a whole social justice agenda.
So it's there as a not directly wanting to
interfere in the internal workings of another
state.
It would leave that to the local Catholic
church, but it operates in unison.
So at the U.N. level, you will find them very,
very much in favor of efforts towards disarmament,
efforts, towards international rapprochement.
A constant advocate for peace.
So if one recalls the war in Iraq in 2003,
Pope John Paul II was really one of the world's
most vocal opponents of the war in Iraq.
And that would be a pretty consistent theme.
You would've seen the papacy intervene at
different stages of international crises.
For example, Pope John the 23rd around the
time of the Cuban missile crisis.
So they will lend the office of the papacy
as a potential sort of neutral broker if that
were ever required.
ROSS: What I'm wondering is that the church
must have a separate set of goals that are
theological or religious in nature.
Their religious duties.
And I'm wondering what intersection you see
between those religious duties and goals,
or missions, and these IR missions that you're
speaking about.
CAMPBELL: Well, that's where it gets to a
really healthy tension for the papacy.
And there's a real tension between what I
would describe the diplomat and the prophetic
voice.
For example, when the Vatican was dealing
in the Cold War with the countries of central
Eastern Europe, you had a real debate between
the prophetic voice of the Vatican that wanted
to call this out what was happening with regards
to human rights, and religious freedom, and
the totalitarian nature of the state.
And then the more diplomatic pragmatists that
were saying, we need some sort of pragmatic
deal in order to allow the church to function
in these countries.
SIERRA: By the way, a lot of popes are mentioned
in this episode, and it’s understandable
if you start to get their names mixed up.
But there are two you’ll really want to
listen for.
The first is the current one, Pope Francis,
who was elected in 2013.
So far, he's best known for advocating for
refugees and climate action.
The other Pope to keep in mind is John Paul
II.
He led the Church from 1978 until his death
in 2005.
He served for a very long time, and enjoyed
a lot of popularity.
Among other things, he was pope during the
end of the Cold War and the fall of the USSR.
ROSS: Throughout our research on this show,
I keep hearing about John Paul II, the pope's
role in Poland during the Cold War, and the
solidarity movement.
And I was hoping that you could relate that
story to us, and kind of maybe give us your
thoughts about what that says about the pope's
influence in global affairs.
CAMPBELL: You know, this was the first time
that a pope was elected from Central and Eastern
Europe.
The first time in four-and-a-half centuries,
where there was a non-Italian elected.
And all of a sudden in 1978, you have the
Archbishop of Kraków elected pope at the
age of 58.
So he's young, and he's coming from the church
behind the Iron Curtain.
So this is someone that immediately in the
Western world is able to give a different
critique of communism.
They're able to give a lived critique of communism.
And with the rise of solidarity out of Gdańsk,
you see during John Paul's visits to Poland,
and the first visit in 1979, and his speech
in Victory Square in Warsaw, you see the full
convening power of the papacy, and the full
voice, speaking to the people in a way that
communism could never get hold of that level
of attention.
ROSS: What do you mean when you say convening
power?
CAMPBELL: Well, you see millions of people
coming to see him.
And if you look in relation to Central and
Eastern Europe, and you look at the role of
John Paul II, at that particular point in
time, you are seeing someone that is holding
up a higher standard and set of values, but
has an understanding of how communism is translating
to the ordinary Pole.
And how it is imposed rather than embraced.
So when you see him arriving in 1979, and
you see him traveling through Poland.
The communist authorities can't keep him out,
but people are naturally wanting to come to
listen to him, and it's not through coercion
or compulsion.
It's a voluntary act.
Whereas, at that period in time, Poland was
living under the imposition of communism.
It wasn't embraced.
So the contrast, the immediate direct contrast
of the images of millions of people coming
to listen to a spiritual leader, talking about
integral human development.
Talking about values, and the virtues that
go with the human spirit.
You have a natural voice that is speaking
to Poland, in a way that Polish communists
could not speak to Poland, and to the ordinary
citizenry.
And that immediately set up a really different,
and difficult dynamic for the Soviet Union,
and it's then allies in the Warsaw pact.
ROSS: So the people coming out into the streets
to hear him speak, they knew that this was
both, you know, Poland is a Catholic country
at this point, under Soviet rule.
And these people know, A) this is my spiritual
leader.
But, B) this guy has been through what I've
been through.
He understands my experiences.
That's a potent mix.
I mean what role do people believe that he
played in the subsequent end to the Cold War?
CAMPBELL: As regards his role in ending the
Cold War, he is certainly one of the key main
figures.
You know, he would share that with Gorbachev.
He would share that with Reagan.
He would be one of those three or four people.
And if you believe that Poland was the first
domino to go.
And if you believe then in the domino effect,
then there is no way that one couldn't say
that John Paul II was one of the three pivotal
figures in the demise of communism in Poland,
and indeed the demise of communism across
Central and Eastern Europe.
BYRNES: Pope John Paul II, basically articulated
in every way available to him that Soviet
communist rule of Poland and the rest of Central
Europe was illegitimate and not permanent.
And of all people, Mikhail Gorbachev once
called Pope John Paul II the first citizen
of global civil society.
And, basically, what he did was he stood up
in Rome, and especially in his visits to Poland,
Warsaw and Krakow, and waved his arms and
said, "We’re Poles.
We're Catholics.
We are not communists in some kind of transnational
Soviet way, and we need to be readmitted or
rejoin a unified Europe that will allow us
to live," what he called, "an authentically
Polish and Catholic life."
SIERRA: John Paul’s long tenure, and his
activism, have ensured his place in the history
books.
Now, we have a new pope.
Pope Francis.
CNBC: Pope Francis delivered a stern warning
to the leader of the Russian orthodox church.
His message, don’t be Vladimir Putin’s
alter boy.
WION: The head of the Catholic Church and
sovereign of the Vatican City State has said
the earth will become uninhabitable if there
is no contrary action taken on climate change.
BBC News: The pope came here with a profound
message on the treatment of refugees.
In essence he said, recognize their humanity.
SIERRA: Pope Francis has a very different
style - I mean, heck he tweets! - and he’s
speaking out about a different set of challenges,
like climate change, and the Russian invasion
of Ukraine.
He also serves during a time of ongoing reckoning
for the church, in which the public is sharply
aware of atrocities committed by Catholic
priests, such as widespread sexual abuse or
crimes against indigenous children in residential
schools.
Pope Francis has taken new steps in acknowledging
and apologizing for these crimes, though many
still say the church has not done nearly enough
to repair the damage.
SIERRA: Alright so I want to understand more
about the current pope, can you tell us what
he has prioritized so far, and whether he’s
been successful?
BYRNES: Whether he was successful or not remains
to be seen, but I think he has certainly made
an effort and has been given an enormous amount
of attention.
He issued an encyclical on climate change
called Laudato Si.
A lot of people have talked about climate
change, but almost no one has talked about
it in the terms he talked about it, which
was that climate change is the greatest threat
to the people around the world who have played
the least role in creating it.
So we, in the United States and the West and
industrialized countries, have created this
historic calamity known as climate change.
And yet, the people who are going to be most
immediately affected by the climate crisis,
dramatic weather events, tsunamis, hurricanes,
etc., and in some parts of the world actually
losing their farming land and maybe even losing
their country, there are places in Southeast
Asia, which will actually be underwater.
And the Pope said in his encyclical that not
only is climate change real and a challenge
to the church's stewardship of God's creation,
which is how he talks about it, but it's also
a moral issue because you and I, when we get
on planes and cars and heat our houses and
have air conditioning, we're actually doing
damage in a kind of unethical way to the most
marginalized people on Earth who had no role
to play in this crisis.
SIERRA: Laudato Si focused catholic attention
on the climate crisis just as the Paris Climate
accords were being written.
And some believe this changed the conversation
within catholic communities.
SIERRA: Is there a flip side to the soft power
coin?
BYRNES: Well, it depends on one's view on
issues.
Right, so you see this in American Catholicism
a lot.
And, and when the Pope is saying something
that a Catholic agrees with, they're like,
"Oh, that's my Pope.
Isn't that wonderful?
And then the Pope says something they don't
like and they say, "Well, that's just the
Pope."
SIERRA: Right.
BYRNES: If someone is going to go out into
the public square, whether it's in the US,
South Africa, China, wherever and say, "Well,
the Pope not only says that climate change
is real and that we have a religious responsibility
to protect the stewardship of God's creation,
but we have to do it because it's a moral
imperative for the poor and the marginalized."
You say that, then what do you say about the
Pope's argument that gender ideology is a
threat to human dignity and that marriage
can only be between one man and one woman
or that abortion or the destruction of a fertilized
egg is always wrong in every sense, you know
the Pope is not a liberal.
He's the Pope.
SIERRA: It's worth jumping in to note that
these interviews were conducted before news
broke of the Supreme Court draft opinion on
abortion.
SIERRA: I mean speaking of those things, from
what I’ve heard about this pope, it seems
like he has de-emphasized some of those issues.
I mean has that changed the Catholic conversation
about LGBTQ issues, or abortion at all?
BYRNES: He hasn't changed any policies or
teachings, but he has certainly tried to change
the conversation.
He came to the United States some years ago,
I forget the year, and he spoke before congress,
a joint session of Congress, a very, very
rare honor given to anyone, much less than
a Catholic Pope.
He started to talk about threats to human
life and human dignity.
I thought, okay, here comes the abortion paragraph.
But it wasn't.
It was the capital punishment paragraph.
He never mentioned abortion.
Now, Pope Francis is strenuously, unambiguously,
clearly opposed to liberalized abortion law.
But that was interesting that he did that.
He also said in a very complicated conversation
some years ago having to do with gay priests,
"Well, who am I to judge?"
Now, many people said, "You're the Pope.
Isn't that what you do?"
And he has spent a lot of time in the ensuing
years trying to be clear about what he meant
by that.
And, I think what he meant was that if you
were a Catholic priest, you were celibate.
You were not engaged in sexual relations,
but you had same sex identity and were a celibate
gay man, who am I to judge?
It's not my business.
But just saying publicly, who am I to judge,
in the context of homosexuality did kind of
open up a little bit of space for this conversation
to be a little different.
But I really don't want to be seen as overstating
that space.
The Pope remains strenuously opposed to same
sex marriage.
And, of course, the church continues throughout
the world and certainly in the United States
to be a major spokesman against reproductive
freedom.
So those policies haven't changed.
But I like the way you said, "Did he change
the conversation?"
A little bit.
That's one of the reasons why some conservatives
are so unhappy with him.
SIERRA: Cool.
You know not changing policy but, I guess,
changing what he thinks is worth focusing
on as well.
BYRNES: I mean maybe even less than that.
SIERRA: Yeah.
Okay.
BYRNES: His central emphasis is on the church
being a church of the poor, for the poor,
in order to help the marginalized.
And, I think it is certainly true that in
that context, he would like a little bit less
discussion of what we Americans call culture
war.
It's not that he doesn't hold those positions.
He doesn't want to talk about that, I think
it's fair to say.
He wants to talk about refugees, climate,
and poverty.
And therefore, he's tried to say, "Let's talk
a little bit less about that and a little
bit more about this."
SIERRA: The Catholic church tends not to change.
But, the Pope has enormous power to shape
what it focuses on.
And that’s why who he is matters.
Whether you are catholic or not, the choices
he makes could impact your life and the things
you care about in the world.
One person who can testify to this is our
guest, Ambassador Campbell, who grew up in
Northern Ireland during the troubles, a period
of prolonged and deadly conflict between Prostestant
UK loyalists and Irish Catholics.
CAMPBELL: I remember as a nine-year-old, in
1979.
It was the first visit of a pope to Ireland.
And the pope couldn't come to Northern Ireland
so we all had to travel across the border
as close as we could get.
And he went to a place in Drogheda, which
had been a scene of one of Cromwell's massacres.
And I remember in 1979, the troubles were
at their height, and it had come just a few
weeks after very horrific events.
In bombings, and including the murder of Lord
Mountbatten.
Very tense time.
And here is this pope who we all know had
come from the experience of communism in Central
and Eastern Europe.
But calling on the men of violence to lay
down their arms.
And it wasn't safe language.
It was bold, prophetic language.
And it also understood the nature of the problem.
It wasn't black and white.
He also talked about the need for dignity,
and for the state to uphold the dignity of
each human being, irrespective of their difference.
And I think, for me, I never forgot that,
that firstly here was someone that came, that
drew attention to this issue, that wasn't
afraid to challenge power.
The power of the British government to do
the right thing in relation to its administration
of Northern Ireland at that time when it wasn't
right.
It wasn't correct, but equally, not to flinch
from a message to people inside the Catholic
community who had chosen to take up arms.
And he would've seen that as his primary goal.
That's who I must communicate to.
And I must ask you-and I think that for me,
I'm not sure that another figure could have
delivered that message, at that time, in that
way, unless they had come out of, say, an
experience like a Pole living under communism.
But that was a very powerful, prophetic voice
that I think resonated.
And certainly sort of would've encouraged
people to go down the route of peace.
And eventually in that case, the peace process.
And it risks taking a position that may be
criticized in the here and now, but will stand
the test of time diplomatically and politically
going forward.
SIERRA: Since this is our last episode with
our fabulous intern Roshni, we are going to
have her read us out today.
RANGWANI: Thanks Gabby!
For resources used in this episode and more
information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters and
take a look at the show notes.
Have a question or some feedback?
Just feel like saying hi?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you are a fan, we’d love it if you
could leave us a review.
Ideally a good one, the more stars the better.
It really does help us get noticed and we
really do appreciate it.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is produced by Asher Ross and Gabrielle
Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Rafaela Siewert is our associate podcast producer.
And I, Roshni Rangwani, was the intern this
semester.
And I loved it.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
Claire Felter.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Shout out to our former intern Natalia Lopez
who pitched us this idea!
We’d also like to thank Richard Haass, Jeff
Reinke and our co-creator Jeremy Sherlick.
For Why It Matters, this is Roshni Rangwani
signing off.
See you soon!